so here we are a thief once dog is angry
the tree an evil stepsister a pirate and
a SAS and most importantly me you are
insufferable
The Guardian must be destroyed
that's a really bad sign sodium's of the
gelatin volume 2:30 pg-13 tickets still
available
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie awesome news
James Gunn confirmed he's doing
guardians of the galaxy three and said a
little bit about where the characters
are headed after infinity war he
confirmed a little bit about the movie
so I'll explain what's going on if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
videos every week the new footage looks
great so just to address that really
quick the Apple askew had a much better
shot of that Drax just like running
right up into its mouth like open wide
Kevin Feige did this big Q&A where he
explains that this is really like early
in the film the guardians are hired by
the sovereign to protect this platform
full of special batteries that powers
almost our entire civilization so it's
just meant to be this fun action set
piece to open the movie with so it's
relatively early in the movie we meet
eatos a living planet relatively early
on to it he explained the whole reason
that the sovereign then turn on the
guardians and go after them is because
Rockets steals a couple of the batteries
thinking that these people are a bunch
of douchebags they're not going to miss
just like one or two batteries so a
Yeshua's character kismet from the
comics is so insulted by that great act
that she declares war on them so it's
kind of funny that this is big galactic
chase to come after them Fox on the run
style just because they steal a couple
batteries for them but really the big
news is James Gunn confirming that he's
going to do guardians 3 he's been on the
fence he's talked about a rocket and
Groot spin-off movie what I think will
happen is he'll do this third Guardian
film and it'll just be a little more
rocket Groot centric whereas most of the
guardians films tend to be centered
around Peter quill in the idea of their
family so that through line will
continue they'll introduce some new
characters but he said some very
specific things about the future of the
characters in phase 3 through infinity
war aware that would leave them in the
next film giving you a pretty good idea
of where the characters are headed so
this is directly from his quote that I'm
reading much of what's happening in the
MCU for the past 10 years or so has been
leading in a big way to Avengers
infinity war guardians of the galaxy vol
3 will happen after that it will
conclude the story for this iteration of
the guardians of the galaxy and help
catapult both old and new Marvel
characters into the next 10 years and
beyond so that means it's going to be a
big jumping off point for these
characters
jumping on point for brand new
characters so I know that makes it sound
kind of weird and it does sound a little
all-new all-different not literally like
if you read the all-new all-different
marvel comics it kind of went down in
flames a little bit people were going
crazy about it I'm not talking about
that I'm just talking about infinity war
being an opportunity because of what
happens during that story to wipe the
slate clean and allow the characters to
go forward in like this fresh new
direction is just sort of this
transitional period because Santos
changes the universe so much with the
Infinity Gauntlet that when you put it
back together it's just a story
opportunity for the writers for the
producers to change things creatively
however they want when they're going
forward in phase four the other part of
James Gunn's announcement was this giant
super post where he professes his love
for his characters so he talks about
them and pretty much lets you know that
they're all going to survive most of
them 99% of them are going to be an
infinity war and then we'll come back
for the next film so you probably
expected that for the main cast from the
first two little returning like Drax
rocket Groot Gamora even nebulas
character who's really cool and
guardians to but the new character
mantis is a bit of a wild card because
we haven't seen a lot from her she's
already confirmed for infinity war and
we know that James Gunn has said that
Kurt Russell's ego the Living Planet
character will continue to be very big
in the MCU
meaning he'll definitely be back for
guardians three and he might even show
up in a Thor movie in the future - but
can we just say how good it is that he's
coming back for Guardian 3 it would have
been a complete disaster for the
franchise if he would have completely
left and somebody else would have come
on to write the script there are so few
people that have the deep comic book
knowledge and love for comics that he
has that are also really good writers
really good producers it have a really
strong distinct creative vision for his
universe that he's created with these
movies so given the right amount of time
whatever he comes up with for guardians
3 is going to be a big slam dunk and
obviously he changes some things from
the comics like ego the Living Planet in
the movies is Peter Quill's father but
it's Jason of spartax in the comics
you'll laugh about this Kevin Feige
actually confirmed that JSON of spartax
does appear during guardians
the galaxy vol 2 but not in the way you
would expect he is in the MCU so it's
canonized but it's a place instead of a
person so when you go see the movie just
be on the lookout for that and I should
actually clear up if there's any
confusion in the comments when he says
that the next guardians movie guardians
volume 3 will come after infinity war
he's talking about after the second
infinity war film which they've already
changed the name of so it's going to be
after 2019 so firmly in phase 4 they
already booked solid with movies for
phase 3 right now but in terms of
story's character evolution based on
some of the stuff they said about the
characters when they're picking up and
Guardians vol 2 you learn a little bit
about the legend of Peter quill and the
Guardians growing in the galaxy people
talk about him being able to hold an
infinity stone that's not a secret that
gets kept the fact that they defeat
Ronan is a big deal the fact that they
saved the galaxy itself so Peter quill
is slowly becoming more and more of an
the more famous they get so as
they build into infinity war think about
what he's going to be like in his
reputation in the galaxy after that so
if you've been reading the comics you
know that there was a crossover arc with
Captain Marvel's character where she
went into space she had a romance with
Peter quill but for a time he deposed
his father it had this absolutely
disastrous attempt to rule the sparta
empire so one way to escalate the
Guardians story would be for Peter quill
to have to be more of a leader because
he's a terrible leader a great Han Solo
character but can you imagine Han Solo
trying to be the leader of an actual big
group of people it would be disastrous
so I don't think that they'll ever get
to realm of Kings or anything like that
because that gets into a lot of Foxx
x-men characters unless they change the
sharing rights but in all the Guardians
movies you have like these really small
runner stories where like Peter Quill's
meeting his father against the backdrop
of this big galactic war with the
sovereign chasing them down so James
Gunn said that with the third movie they
will try to defy your expectations so in
the way that the second movie is so much
bigger and grander while still being a
small movie compared to the first movie
the same thing will be true for the
third movie so it's not like they're
just going to keep getting bigger and
bigger
bigger the way they did with the
Avengers movies because that's a recipe
for failure so feel like rocket and
Groot will continue to be the emotional
core of the Guardians Groot will get
bigger depending on how much time is
passed they say only two months has gone
by when the start of guardians to picks
up from the last guardians film so
they've officially broken the Marvel
timelines like things don't move in real
time anymore it used to be like if six
months went by before the next movie
came out then in the timeline it was six
months later but now they're kind of
jumping around in time a little bit so
that explains why Groot is still so
small like Kevin Feige said that he
basically just stepped out of the pot
he's still dumb as rocks and even though
it's going to be a long time before the
third guardians movie comes out it would
be awesome to go back to his home planet
so maybe by that time he will have fully
grown back to his adult self well let me
know in the comments what story do you
want them to pull from for guardians 3
just remember that they really don't do
the comic book arcs there was a little
bit of annihilation conquest in the
first guardians film because that was
the story of how the guardians comes
together this iteration of the Guardians
so the second movie is even more off
comic book even though they're doing a
lot of Easter eggs from the comics like
egos a living planet is a huge comic
book character he's one of the most
obscure biggest literally biggest Marvel
villains but there haven't really been
any big stories where he's been tied to
Peter quill so he's way off book even
though he is doing a lot of comic-book
things but I know a lot of people are
holding out hope for venom space night
I'm not expecting that but that would be
a back door for them integrating the
venom character into the MCU if they're
going to go that route there's still so
many questions about the venom
spider-man franchise because Sony has
its own thing going on and it sounds
like James Gunn kind of likes to play in
his own sandbox as much as possible like
he's going to great lengths to keep any
other humans from Earth from appearing
in his movie and even though Earth does
appear during guardians - he says the
Guardians themselves do not travel to
earth the way that Thor travels to earth
during Thor Ragnarok but what's going to
happen next is is because before this
big news drop I was getting ready to do
a Justice League Darkseid video that'll
be the next video I post I think there's
going to be some new spider-man footage
relatively soon they'll probably be a
new flash trailer so whatever
ends up dropping I will totally do a
video for it believe all your requests
in the comments below so while you wait
for that next video you can click here
to rewatch the Star Wars trailer and you
can click here to rewatch thor ragnarok
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five see you guys in the next video
you